avant que la vidéo commence j'aimerais
vous parler de notre partenariat du jour
c'est un outil que j'utilise au
quotidien et qui me permet d'avoir accès
à de nombreux films et séries
indisponible en france pour le moment
vous l'aurez compris cette vidéo est
sponsorisé par north bay pn le mc eu
avance considérablement en termes de
production et avec la nouvelle stratégie
de marvel studios depuis la période de
qu'ovide tous les films proposés par la
firme sorte sur dix n'est plus seulement
deux mois après leur sortie au cinéma je
pense que vous avez fait le lien cela
veut dire que thor love and thunder ou
encore dr strange multiverse of madness
sont disponibles sur la plateforme
malheureusement ce n'est pas accessible
dans tous les pays et en france il nous
faut attendre un certain moment avant
d'avoir accès à ses productions c'est là
que north bpn intervient en un seul clic
vous pouvez changer votre localisation
pour par exemple le canada et du coup
cela vous permet d'accéder aux contenus
disponibles dans le pays et en plus de
cette fonctionnalité normes européennes
est un outil qui protège contre les
criminels et la surveillance sur le web
accessible depuis six appareils
différents nord bpn possède également
une incroyable vitesse d'exécution grâce
à ses cinq mille 200 serveurs répartis
dans plus de 60 pays donc si vous
souhaitez accéder au réseau internet
mondial et maîtrisez votre activité sur
le web en toute sécurité optez pour
north bay pn et profiter de l'offre sur
deux ans avec quatre mois offerts et un
prix nettement réduit pour l'occasion
tout ça satisfait ou remboursé sur 30
jours n'hésitez pas à accéder au lien
disponible en descriptions merci à
nantes bpn que la vidéo commence
bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans cette grosse vidéo dédiée à
l'équipe des thunderbolts effectivement
comme vous avez dû en être témoin marvel
studios durant les annonces du d23 a
décidé de nous dévoiler les membres
principaux de cette nouvelle team dont
le film est prévue pour le 26 juillet
2024 juste après captain america 4 new
world order et qui va clôturer du coup à
la phase 5 pour être honnête parmi
toutes les annonces disponibles durant
le des 23 la révélation de la team des
thunderbolts est la chose qui m'a le
plus hype et pourquoi cela du coup et
bien tout simplement car le film est
prévu pour dans longtemps il est celui
qui va terminer la phase 5 avant
d'arriver au grand final de la saga du
multivers via la phase 6 nous révéler
aujourd'hui en 2022 le roster des fender
boels c'est nous dévoiler en partie la
direction de plusieurs intrigues qui se
sont mises en place durant la phase iv
et élément qui pèse son poids c'est que
par le biais de la saga du multivers
marvel a pour stratégie d'utiliser la
fin comme introduction pour deviner
l'avenir ce que je veux dire par là
c'est que comme la mise en lumière via
la série lockheed celui qui demeure le
gagnant de la guerre multi vercel guerre
qui par le biais de la fin des temps est
en train de se relancer pour donner à
terme avengers the gang dynastie et
avengers sicre et wars
et bien justement tout cela et de vie
nabeul car marvel a repris cette
stratégie en dévoilant la fin de la saga
du multivers avec la révélation de ces
deux films avengers et du coup ils sont
en train de reproduire la même chose
avec le film fender bolt dont le roster
nous dévoile la finalité de la mise en
place de plusieurs éléments de la phase
4 mai avant de rentrer dans le dur et
les grandes théories permettez moi de
vous éclairer concernant la nature est
l'essence même des thunderbolts et du
coup bas les membres qui vont composer
cette équipe dans le mcb thunderbolt
sont une équipe plutôt particulière
effectivement il ne faut pas les voir
comme une team de super méchants car ce
n'est pas vraiment le cas mais plutôt
une team de personnages
plutôt gris de par leur histoire et leur
vécu et qui souhaite redorer leur blason
en volant la vedette aux avengers et
autres super héros adulé par le monde à
l'origine à l'initiative du baron zemo
les thunderbolts sont une véritable
équipe d'avengers 2.0 destiné à devenir
les principaux concurrents des vengeurs
n'ayant pas peur de se salir les mains
cet hymne d'avengers ce douteux n'hésite
pas à s'occuper des tâches les plus
ingrates dans le but d'atteindre la
rédemption qu'il convoite et à terme
devenir eux mêmes des héros médiatisé et
apprécié du peuple néanmoins l'élément
le plus important et pertinent pour moi
qui symbolise l'essence même des
thunderbolts c'est que du fait que la
team est composé de personnages
diamétralement opposés à ceux des
avengers nous révèle que leurs
concurrents sont au final tout aussi
doute que et du coup que les
thunderbolts se sont tout aussi légitime
que les avengers à devenir une véritable
équipe populaire de super héros la
présence des thunderbolts ce nous
dévoile en fait les zones d'ombré
concernant la team des avengers puisque
nous avons qu'une seule et même team de
super héros depuis toujours la
population n'a d'autre choix que de les
annuler les avengers ont le monopole de
l'industrie entre guillemets un si je
puis dire des super héros sauf qu'avec
l'existence d'une team concurrentes il y
a désormais la possibilité de comparer
les protagonistes la population peut dès
à présent ouvrir les yeux en détail sur
les agissements des avengers et à terme
apprécier les thunderbolts pour des
qualités que les avengers n'ont pas et
justement c'est le moment parfait pour
mettre en lumière les membres de cette
nouvelle team dans le mc hué relier
l'univers à tout ça
vous n'êtes pas sans savoir que l'équipe
des avengers dont mc eu à traverser bon
nombre d'épisodes sombre entre les
crises de colère du lks la guerre civile
à cause des accords de soko vie les
nombreux dommages collatéraux dus aux
batailles des avengers ou tout
simplement l'infiltration d'hydra dans
le shield tout ça sont des éléments qui
font défaut aux avengers mais ayant le
monopole des super héros des
super-pouvoirs depuis le début du mc
hugh que ce soit la population ou même
nous en tant que spectateur nous fermons
les yeux sur tous ces agissements car
seuls les avengers ont le pouvoir de
protéger la population
et ça il ya un personnage qui en a
parfaitement conscience et dont le plan
déjà mis en route va permettre de ternir
l'image des avengers pour mettre en
lumière sa future nouvelle team il
s'agit bien évidemment de valentina
allegra des fontaines dévoilé pour la
première fois dans falcone et le soldat
de l'hiver venti navia seulement sa
première intervention nous permet de
comprendre et d'expliquer pourquoi
l'équipe des thunderbolts est composé
des personnages révélés lors du day 23
[Musique]
les avengers sont très médiatisées de
par leur aventure ces derniers sont
devenus des icônes des symboles ils ont
atteint l'apogée ultime en termes de
popularité et justement à qui profite à
terme tous ces éléments
ce sont les gouvernements bien
évidemment les personnages puissants du
monde se servent des avengers pour
accroître leur pouvoir politique
ils ont des intérêts à utiliser les
super héros
tout comme rose qui souhaitaient avoir
le contrôle total des avengers les
accords de soko vie avait totalement cet
objectif le gouvernement américain
utilise la puissance du symbole du
bouclier de captain america pour avoir
un super héros sous leur contrôle black
widow et tente une tueuse originaire de
la russie elle a dû suer corps et âme
pour trouver la rédemption en amérique
au point d'être redevable à vis envers
le shield sauf que de la même manière
qu'une pièce possède deux facettes et
bien de l'autre côté nous retrouvons
ceux qui n'ont pas eu la chance d'être
promu est utilisé par les gens puissants
du monde les sondeurs boys sont composés
des ro délaissés et jetés comme des
kleenex par les gouvernements et autres
personnages puissants du monde john
walker pion du gouvernement américain
pour avoir le total contrôle de la
puissance que désigne le symbole captain
america finalement il a été délaissé car
désapprouvé médiatiquement alors qu'il
obéissait aux ordres depuis le début réd
guardian bras droit de jack of l'un des
personnages les plus puissants de la
russie et dirigeants de la chambre rouge
où sont formés les veuves noires à terme
alexis sera trahi par son propre patron
et jeté en prison car dre cov n'avait
plus besoin de lui elena belova et
antonia l'ias taskmaster toutes deux des
pions et des outils de drake of
remplaçables à n'importe quel moment
elles sont victimes depuis leur plus
jeune âge des intérêts de la russie
ghost son père a été fourvoyé par hank
pym au sein du shield la faisant devenir
instable sur le plan moléculaire à cause
d'un accident lié au chant quantique
dont ses parents trouveront la mort à
cause de sa condition le schilde
l'utilisera pour effectuer le sale
boulot en échange de lui promettre de la
guérir sauf que bien évidemment son
pouvoir est trop utile pour le shield et
jamais ces derniers n'ont prévu de la
guérir alors que pourtant sa condition
lui cause des douleurs atroces elle
n'aura que pour seule issue de fuguer et
devenir une fugitive alors qu'elle
n'avait rien fait à la base et enfin
bucky le soldat de l'hiver le produit
ultime en matière de super soldats issus
des expériences russe désignée comme une
arme depuis le début nombreuses ont été
les personnes à vouloir exploiter
l'outil que symbolise bug qui est à
cause de ces agissements téléguidé à
distance par idra barnes est et restera
toujours un délaissé et méprisé du
gouvernement américain jamais ces
derniers ne lui laisseront la vie facile
et il sera même au final en cavale la
plupart du temps seul le wakanda lui
permettra d'atteindre la rédemption et
la paix est ce que vous voyez le point
commun entre tous ces personnages ils
sont tous victimes des gens puissants du
monde ils n'ont tous été que des outils
permettant d'accroître les intérêts de
ces derniers sauf qu'une fois qu'ils
sont devenus problématiques ou qu'il n'y
avait plus d'utilité de les utiliser ils
ont été soit trahi je t'ai délaissés ou
bien traquer et c'est justement là leur
plus grande force et valentina le sait
ils se sont tous émancipée de l'emprise
de leur mettre entre guillemets et sont
aujourd'hui prêts pour la rédemption et
la rébellion néanmoins je sais ce que
vous allez me dire ce n'est pas parce
que les personnages ont subi des
injustices que voilà tout d'un coup ils
ont envie de créer l'anarchie
effectivement c'est vrai et ce n'est pas
le but de toute façon des thunderbolts
on va mentionné du coup précisément le
cas de bucky car je sais que c'est un
petit peu la grande surprise
voir dans l'équipe des thunderbolts
alors pourquoi le soldat de l'hiver
rejoindrait cette nouvelle équipe eh
bien j'ai une possible explication pour
le reste de l'équipe ce n'est pas très
étonnant de les voir dans l'équipe des
thunderbolts y est lena et walker en
font déjà partie régordane et taskmaster
à la fin du film black widow sont partis
avec elena du coup voilà on pourrait se
dire facilement que valentina aurait
approché tout le groupe d'un coup et
puis s'ils ont su les comics valentina
est une russe qui a infiltré à la fois
hydra et le shield vu comment leur
hayward yann et patriotique cela coule
de source de le voir travailler avec
elle pour retrouver son heure de gloire
plutôt qu'avec bas des américains et
puis elena de par son enfance dans
l'ohio avec sa fausse famille et l'
influence de sa soeur elle est très
attiré par les états unis alors que
barrett guardian et antonia beaucoup
moins bref et ghost bas elle a été très
peu développé mais elle a été utilisée
est rejetée par le shield et n'a aucune
véritable attache donc voilà revenons-en
à bucky barnes reste quelqu'un qui veut
faire le bien et malgré la terrible vie
qu'il a eu il s'efforce de se racheter
aux états unis et se réintégrer pourtant
je vois une raison qui le pousserait à
rejoindre les thunderbirds c'est le cas
du wakanda comme vous le savez à la fin
du film black panthères tchalla souhaité
modifier la politique du pays suite à
son affrontement avec kiel mongueurs il
voulait que le wpt à kandahar est d'être
dans son coin à l'écart du monde et que
désormais le pays partageraient ses
savoirs et ses connaissances avec le
reste du monde et du coup nous le savons
black panther 2 va nous montrer cette
ouverture sauf que tout ne semble pas
bien se passer effectivement nous allons
en être témoin mais étant donné que le
wakanda est très avancé
technologiquement parlant et possède la
ressource la plus précieuse c'est à dire
le vibranium et bien cela va attirer de
nombreux protagonistes a récupéré cette
ressource et notamment des organisations
agissant au nom de leur pays respectif
nous aurons les réponses dans le film
mais il semblerait que dans le trailer
le wakanda soient victimes de raids des
états unis pour récupérer le vibranium
et les secrets des oies quand des sauf
que bucky possède désormais des liens
forts avec le wakanda considéré comme le
loup blanc ce dernier a été sauvés et
recueillis par ce pays et possède donc
une dette infinie envers le wakanda
c'est le seul pays qui a bien traités le
soldat de l'hiver et qui lui a donné une
chance la preuve en est avec son bras
mécanique c'est un présent de tshala et
du wakanda en verbe qui est le loup
blanc le possède encore aujourd'hui et
c'est là que c'est intéressant encore
une fois les intérêts des états unis
sont la cause d'événements tragiques et
bucky dont l'amérique a toujours négligé
son existence est bien est aujourd'hui
témoin des agissements de ces derniers
envers le pays qui l'a recueillie et qui
a pris soin de lui sauf qu'étant un
solitaire aux états unis mais qui n'a
pas vraiment la possibilité de faire
quelque chose et c'est là que l'équipe
des thunderbolts intervient par le biais
de valentina et de cette nouvelle équipe
b qui peut agir et intervenir en tant qu
héros sans dépendre du gouvernement
américain et c'est là tout l'intérêt par
le biais des thunderbolts ils pourraient
venir en aide aux wakanda et d'autres
causes et en plus avoir de la
reconnaissance de manière indépendante
et sans avoir de répercussion derrière
depuis toujours bucky est rejeté et mis
sur le côté et en plus sa personne et le
wakanda sont mis à mal par les états
unis sauf que voilà ça tire sur la corde
ça tire sur la corde mais le loup blanc
ne va pas rester fidèle indéfiniment
c'est une occasion en or pour lui de
redonner son blason et agir pour des
causes justes sans passer par les
intérêts du gouvernement
bon et maintenant il est temps de
rentrer un peu plus dans les théories
mais juste avant il y a quand même des
éléments que j'estime très important et
qu'il faut souligner étant donné que
thunderbolt c'est le dernier film de la
phase 5 et qu'en plus il réunit la
grande majorité des personnages
introduits lors de la phase 4 il est sûr
à 100% qu'il est le film qui va clôturer
plusieurs des grandes intrigues ollier
sur le plan terrestre et en plus de cela
je vous en avais déjà parlé mais une
certaine poésie se dégage de la fin de
la phase 5 puisque thunderbolt vient
juste après captain america 4 new world
order nous savons que les deux films
seront reliés et c'est une évidence et
justement de par les événements de la
phase 6 avec avengers the gang dynastie
et avengers sicre et wars la thématique
c'est que nos héros seront dans
l'obligation de confronter d'autres
héros provenant d'univers différents par
le biais de captain america 4 et le film
thunderbolt nous retrouvons clairement
cette même thématique puisque un
affrontement va forcément découler de
ces films opposant les avengers qui
serait à fortes chances guidé par sam le
nouveau captain america et les
thunderbolts qui débarque pour créer la
concurrence du coup une team de super
héros contre une autre team de super
héros c'est très important de le
souligner et du coup par rapport aux
théories il y a eu des révélations lors
du d23 concernant captain america 4 new
world order c'est le grand retour de
samuel stento alias le leader dans les
comics pour être du coup bas le grand
méchant de captain america 4 cela peut
sembler peut-être anodin pour certains
mais c'est une information cruciale qui
tease de nombreuses choses par rapport à
l'avenir du mc et notamment l'intrigué
du film thunderbolt je m'explique comme
vous le savez le développement de hulk
dans le mca a toujours été compliqué
tout simplement car ce dernier
appartient ta universal du coup marvel
studios a passé des accords avec l'autre
film pour pouvoir intégrer hulk dans
leur univers mais malheureusement
n'ayant jamais eu à 100% le personnage
hulk a toujours été mis au second plan
et rares ont été les intrigues
développées concernant le personnage
sauf que tous ceux ci semblent eux
désormais révolue il y à des rumeurs
comme quoi marvel aurait la possession
total de hulk en 2023 rien ne nous
permet de véritablement le confirmer
cependant je ne sais pas si vous l'avez
remarqué mais dernièrement hulk et tous
qui l'entourent reviennent en force dans
le mc eu la série shulk est arrivé
banner revient sur le devant la scène et
nous tease une nouvelle intrigue propre
à son personnage emile blanche ce qui a
fait son grand retour dans she hulk et
tout ça c'est très lourd de sens
pourquoi cela eh bien depuis toujours le
film the incredible hulk sorti en 2008 à
éternellement été mis de côté au point
même qu'à terme nous ne savions plus
réellement si ce dernier était canon et
officiels omc sauf que près de 15 ans
plus tard énormément d'éléments liés au
film refont surface dans l'univers
marvel est actuellement ces éléments
n'ont jamais été aussi importants à
prendre en compte vous allez comprendre
déjà rien que le retour de l'abomination
c'est énorme mais là avec les
révélations du d23 samuel stern va du
coup revenir et cette fois ci en tant
que grand vilain de captain america new
world order là je peux vous dire que
désormais tout est tracé l'aboutissement
de la série she hulk et la création et
l'avènement d'un nouveau hulk dans le
premier épisode banner nous explique
qu'il a pris le son de sa cousine
jennyfer pour comprendre comment ces
dernières a pu devenir une hulk
néanmoins après ces explications banner
souligne très clairement qu'il doit
impérativement désintégrer le sens
récupéré de sa cousine car entre de
mauvaises mains cela pourrait donner la
naissance d'une grande menace dans
l'épisode 3 jennifer est victime d'une
agression ou ses attaquants avaient pour
objectif de voler le sens de l'avocate
et ces derniers ont agi sous les ordres
d'un grand patron bon tout ça on en a
déjà parlé dans la dernière vidéo le
grand patron pourrait être pourquoi pas
valentina le cailly de titania quelqu'un
d'autre bref mais désormais nous avons
les moyens de creuser plus loin le fait
que samuel stern alias le leader soit le
grand méchant de captain america 4
permet de confirmer qu'à terme nous
allons être témoins de la naissance d'un
nouveau hulk pour rappel samuel est un
scientifique très relié au personnage de
hulk dans l'incroyable hulk de 2008 il
va collaborer avec banner et récupérer
le sens de ce dernier pour tenter de
possiblement le soigne et samuel va donc
avoir un échantillon du sang de banner
et il va le dupliquer et l'expérimenté
pour con prendre tous ses secrets et à
la fin du film il est celui qui va
donner naissance à l'abomination en
donnant une partie du sang de banner à
emil blonsky la particularité de samuel
c'est qu'il est le scientifique le plus
expérimenté concernant le phénomène hulk
c'est réellement ce qui le symbolise et
du coup par le biais des événements de
l'incroyable hulk si ce dernier fait à
terme son grand retour en tant que
vilain c'est forcément parce que c'est
relié à hulk il se pourrait même que ce
soit lui qui est envoyé les démolisseurs
pour récupérer le sens de jennifer
waters
pour continuer par rapport à tout ça
puisque nous savons que la finalité
serait la création d'un nouveau hulk et
bien il y a énormément d'éléments dans
le mc u qui prennent désormais sens
depuis toujours et c'est la thématique
principale de la série falcone et le
soldat de l'hiver énormément deux
protagonistes dans le gouvernement des
états unis est a dit strauss ont cherché
à redévelopper le sérum de super soldats
pour créer deux nouvelles entités sur
puissante aux ordres des dirigeants mais
à la fin de la série la problématique
des super soldats est désormais révolu
les derniers ces roms ont été détruits
les derniers membres des flaques
smashwords qui étaient des super soldats
ont été tués et le scientifique qui
avait pour mission de reproduire le
sérum a été assassiné donc voilà l'ère
des super soldats c'est fini néanmoins
la scène post générique de la série nous
avait amené un élément très intéressant
sharon carter a été blanchi et a
retrouvé un poste dans le gouvernement
des états unis sauf que comme les
membres des thunderbolts cette dernière
a avait été trahie et jeté par le
gouvernement et ça elle ne l'a jamais
oubliée et elle s'est même reconstruite
aujourd'hui en tant que power broker et
justement quand sharon passe un coup de
fil dans la scène post générique
elle nous apprend que désormais qu'elle
est de retour dans le gouvernement le
sérum du super soldat
c'est quelque chose de plus vraiment
intéressant car à partir de maintenant
sharon a accès à des secrets beaucoup
plus exaltant et rentable je vous le
mets dans le mille qu'est ce qui est
plus intéressant que le sérum du super
soldat eh bien les secrets permettant la
création de nouveaux hulk la série de
falcon nous dit très clairement que le
sérum n'est désormais plus accessible et
de par les récents de production et
informations concernant l'avenir du mc
nous savons que nous nous tournons
plutôt vers la création d'un ou
plusieurs nouveaux uc et là il y à un
autre lien très intéressant que nous
pouvons faire vous le savez aussi bien
que moi une des figures emblématiques
des thunderbolts ce c'est le raid punk
valentina était très au fait concernant
le sérum du super soldat c'est même
d'ailleurs la raison de pourquoi elle a
recruté john walker dans sa team donc
forcément avec l'avènement des hulk par
le biais de chiottes de banner de
l'abomination et possiblement l'arrivée
d'oscar valentina va souhaiter à terme
créer son propre hulk et justement il se
pourrait que sharon à l'époque était au
téléphone avec valentina pour lui donner
accès aux secrets du gouvernement et
notamment les informations liées au
phénomène de hulk récupérer dans
l'incroyable hulk de 2008 et pour
continuer il faut que nous parlons
maintenant du personnage de baron zemo
alors c'est peut-être surprenant pour
vous que ces mots ne fasse pas partie
des thunderbolts mais je vous avoue que
pour moi c'est tout l'un verse j'aurais
été très surpris de voir que ces mots
fasse partie des thunderbolts pourquoi
cela et bien tout simplement car ces
mots et hors catégorie il est un
électron libre
agissons pour lui même et par rapport
aux comics il est plutôt un leader par
rapport au thunderbolt il est au dessus
de l'équipe dans falcone et le soldat de
livers remo fait tout pour que le sérum
du super-soldat devienne à terme
inaccessible il est celui qui a détruit
les derniers sérum et depuis sa prison
il est celui qui a orchestré la mort des
derniers flac smash up valentina
catégorise même et mode amis et fait
planer le doute quant au fait qu'elle
ait possiblement en lien avec la mort
des derniers flac smash up
si valentina dit vrai cela veut donc
dire que ces mots travaille en secret
avec la comtesse le fait d'avoir rendu
le sérum du super-soldat inaccessible
permet d'ailleurs de rendre john walker
alias us agent encore plus unique
puisqu'il est désormais l'un des rares
protagonistes avec le raid guardian
aussi à posséder le sérum et maintenant
bah ils font partie des thunderbolts
donc c'est parfait cela a été confirmé
de toutes façons et cela coule de source
mais est mort et apparaîtra dans le film
thunderbolt le personnage possède les
mêmes objectifs que cette équipe et mode
et voue une haine aux intouchables
avengers il est à l'origine de l'as
civil war il est celui qui a monté les
avengers les uns contre les autres et
qui a révélé que les membres de l'équipe
était très loin d'être parfait
forcément zemo approuveraient la
création d'une nouvelle équipe
concurrente aux avengers dont les
actions ont tué la famille du baron donc
voilà il ya de fortes chances que ce
dernier travaille avec valentina et
qu'au final à terme toutes les intrigues
sont reliés au thunderbolt et enfin pour
conclure il faut quand même rester les
pieds sur terre et ne pas non plus se
précipiter je pense vraiment que le film
fender bol ce nous montrera l'avènement
d'une équipe composée de seulement six
personnages tout simplement car à
l'origine les avengers et es6 et
valentina du coup serait l'équivalente
de nick fury mais à terme il se peut que
l'équipe grandissent et c'est même quand
même plutôt sûr d'ailleurs par rapport
aux comics valentina et fiori sont très
relier est extrêmement proche donc
peut-être que nous serons témoins de
cette future liaison dans le mc eu
écoute et on va s'arrêter là j'ai plein
de théories concernant les thunderbolts
mais bon je pense que c'est peut-être un
peu tôt et la vidéo est quand même déjà
bien assez longue donc voilà ce sera
l'occasion d'en reparler et de faire une
vidéo dédiée j'espère en tout cas que ma
vidéo vous a plu j'ai essayé d'être le
plus complet possible je vous ai
clairement partager ma vision des choses
donc n'hésitez pas à me faire le maximum
de retours et à me partager en
commentaire du coup vos théories et vos
idées ce serait très intéressant à lire
n'oubliez pas non plus de laisser un
petit bout ce bleu c'est très important
et surtout surtout à vous abonner à la
chaîne nous nous rapprochons très
dangereusement des cent mille abonnés
c'est clairement la le rush final et je
me dis qu'il ya clairement moyens en
plus de les avoir avant d'arriver à 2023
donc n'hésitez pas bien sûr à nous
rejoindre sur ce c'était un argot rock
que le lionheart soit avec vous allez
ciao tout le monde
[Musique]